welcome to this video yep and this is
white again I'm playing swap yeah that
Matthias Mueller alright Ike I keep
forgetting that played him so often
Malaya's 9 f 6 that's a good reply
against the 93 opening sets my wings
actually what I play so we get a kind of
very soft opening Bishop f4 heads
recently become fashionable not quite
sure why but with Jabbar played it quite
a bit I don't really see the point i
have to admit but ok i'm going to play
it a little bit here and see what
happens going for FIA getting maybe
getting you for next leading at least to
some kind of open position where I don't
have a dell development problem or
anything of the kind well it's not bad
actually not a bad position yeah I
wonder is he a French defense player if
he is mmhmm yeah if I've is probably
wrong here and I don't know if taking on
d5 is making much sense ok I don't know
what to do let's play a waiting move
that actually prepares in some way if
five but it also just waits a move and
sees what happens hmm how do I play that
here ok that that's definitely on the
agenda maybe Queenie 24 route d1
possibly d4 is a move though ok I can go
to be one and if I've next
ok
yeah let's put this here opposite the
Queen
at least I'm well developed I don't have
any problem like that okay he cheeks
that giving me the bishop pair oh really
huh anything else they're probably not
let's take it so I just sorry yeah
interesting but I want to keep this
Bishop though let's remove it from
before
ideas like mm-hmm Bishop b5 would be
nice to get in or another interesting
let's put this on the board not think
too long so he just doesn't mind that I
take him here yep understandable
actually so let's go see for here take
away important squares on d5 and I'm
also giving my bishop retweet squares
all the way to a 1 if necessary I need
the rooks to participate I wonder is
this a way to do it f4 maybe let's go
and form it also makes the capture on f6
far more likely taking GTX Queen g4
check and you cannot play Queen g5 then
okay probably
I bishop pair should be really quite ok
check King edge to I don't know it's
difficult to say getting into that long
diagonal can always be shaky for some
capture on h3 but this is decisions like
King age 10 King edge today they can
really can they can take your
photographer too much time
mm-hmm you okay bishop where I can also
go to d4 actually taking it wins the
Queen but I don't think it's is that
helpful so let's go back all the way
Queen g4 is my next move I think unless
he stops it somehow
so he just went back I want the I want
the rook 1e5 that possible so i can
check now take on f6 GTX Quincy for
checking edge eight Queen edge for King
g7 and and then rookie 3g three would be
great but I don't get it in and rookie
five would be brilliant but again i
don't i don't have that hmm
she soon I don't have
okay lackner nananananana see four years
Rookie three unfortunately I what a
shame okay okay chat and I have to go
with that and see if I can do something
here I actually can I can look f3 look
at three as possible now it wasn't
before Bishop g6 had to take first
so what is he doing this one yes
checking age seven still holds g-form is
rubbish
time warning huh I really defended that
that's stuff noise
he really defended that i'm not sure if
rookie 3 is even good move but at least
uh okay let's do that it seems dangerous
ham
rupee one maybe just willing this is
also possible maybe Queen g5s a little
bit okay have them check having a huge
time edge now it's not--she's got no
check right so here ya for Luke c8
that's dangerous at least that is
defending don't believe all that it
really is right Jesus and queens you one
Wow
check black forfeits on time I don't
know what is this position huh yes
justice and the check all of a sudden
chair that looks great yeah how am i
screwing it up here so she can really
generate to believe what is best then
queen f form it's not not winning
amazing gym so we had this this weird
weird opening that held very dangerous
but maybe it wasn't that bad check IP
should be six I thought bishop deform I
saw Bishop t4b should be six wins the
exchange but it's actually not that easy
I didn't see it at all but it's not that
easy it's not that I willingly decided
not to do it because he gets a um gets a
nice Knight to g5 okay but I wanted to
play for the attack f5 was interesting I
didn't see that check after that the
engine is giving a decoy seems to be
okay for black yeah I was he will be
defended that very well up to the very
end okay well thanks for watching